The Pythagorean Theorem Can Be Proved in Many
Ways and We've Already Seen One
Previously Here Let's Look at Another Way in Which We Can
Prove It It's Relatively Easy Let's
draw a square with the length of all
its sides equal to c units Now we need
to  Construct a triangle with side c
as the hypotenuse so we draw these two
lines perpendicular to each other This becomes a
right triangle with this s The
hypotenuse
Let the length of this side b a and that of
this side b b We need to prove that a  s p b s e c s s
this is a square the
length of this side will also b c now let's complete this right
triangle this length will be a
units this will be
units in the same way let's complete this
triangle this
will  B a right triangle with
sides a b and c Drawing this line gives us
another right angle triangle with sides a
b and
c In each of the triangle the side with length c
is the hypotenuse What we should be
interested in finding is the area of ​​the
Larger square
Other
side of this quadrature will be equal to a-
b but what we are interested in finding is
the area of ​​larger square and then
discussing about how we can find the area of ​​the
larger square.
Multiply by Side So She
Writes The Area As c Ta c V Equals c S
z Does not use the formula but instead thinks
of a different way to find the area
of ​​this square which says that the area of ​​the
largest square will equal the area of
The Five Figures Formed With In The Square
Four Of Which Are Triangle And One Square
So The Area Of The Larger Square Will Be
Equal To The Area Of The Four Triangles
Plus The Area Of The Smaller Square
Formed In The
Center First Let's Look At The
Triangle  Each of the triangles has the height as
a units and the base edge as b units so we can write
the total area of ​​the four triangles
as 4 times 1/2 a but what is the area
of ​​the smaller square formed in the center as the length
of each of its sides is a a -
b Its area will be a - b scored All we need to do
now is work this out 4 ta 1/2 a
will equal 2ab And using the identity we can write this
as a s - 2ab +  b
s 2ab and - 2ab cancel out and what we get
on the right hand side is a s + b s we are
talking about the area of ​​the same
square so we can say c s e a s sp b
sk so if we have a right  Triangle with
sides a and b and hypotenuse
theorem says that sk will equal a sk
b
[music]
sk